today we're working on a story that's
either a suicide or a murder I didn't
realized that we were going to be
jumping into something so big right away
it's big and it's not big depending on
how you see it
terrible things happen every day in this
city oh I got the grand final of burn
those clothes Parker you got bear blows
the balloons my customers don't buy that
high-end stuff over here I understand
the insatiable urge to procreate with
your boyfriend but I've never seen Scott
think deeply about anything other than
your body I just the way to have people
I know and I love you for that those are
the detectives on the case today is your
lucky day I have a 10 working
relationship with these guys Ronnie this
itself from New York news so where you
guys headed no one you know where we're
headed
yes that's correct hey this is Owen this
is Benny
he loves this I can't tell you that you
you seem like the kind of kid that would
spread that information
I can't believe I put naked pictures on
the internet and I love of my life
explicitly told you the consequences if
photos are available to any Greek want
them I think I may be you saying that
before but always listen another fan of
confrontation there sure I'm not crying
my eyes are always moist I'm too
emotionally detached from life to cry
[Music]
Ernie was me Melanie thinks I'm a
lesbian
she thinks that because I've only ever
been this girl I was like they're after
the white she didn't look like a
murderer to me she's a decent woman
again they got that music in my hospital
it's a tender spot vulnerable come over
here nice and easy
I'm only going to break one of your legs
keep running and I'm going to break them
both where's the road over either of my
legs never heard of it
[Music]
you have to get tossed Claire go
existence in Twinkies put this job run
away and go home lawyer
[Music]
[Music]